[Music]
Lindemann if you'll indulge me I have an
announcement to make
let me explain what's going on here okay
sitting here before me are some of the
most prestigious awards and artists can
receive the Oscar the Golden Globe the
BAFTA the Screen Actors Guild Award the
Peabody Award and of course the Nobel
Peace Prize
ladies and gentlemen people work their
entire lives in an attempt to earn just
one of these incredible awards but if
you asked me they're all garbage
[Music]
there's only one award one award in the
world that truly matters I'm talking of
course about the MTV Movie Award
ah the golden popcorn isn't she
beautiful well I'm proud to announce
that I Conan O'Brien will realize my
lifelong dream of hosting the 2015 Conan
O'Brien host the 23rd annual MTV Movie
Awards broadcast live from the Nokia
Theatre on Sunday April 13 and folks
don't worry true detective isn't on that
night we checked and this season of The
Walking Dead will be over by then too
actually Game of Thrones is on that
night but they'll repeat it every four
hours on HBO's 2:37
thanks Andy so tune in Sunday April 13th
why host the MTV Movie Awards I'm
humbled I'm honored and as of late this
morning I'm contractually obligated
[Applause]